la france est le pays européen où l'on
meurt le plus au travail selon la
confédération européenne des syndicats
voici ce qu'il se passe cette 1800
travailleurs sont morts en france au
cours des dix dernières années selon la
csc plus du double qu'en allemagne c'est
également le chiffre le plus élevé en
europe est encore plus inquiétant la
france est le seul pays où cette
tendance reste en hausse actuellement
douze travailleurs 17 de leurs activités
chaque jour ouvré en europe d'après les
estimations de la crs les syndicats
appellent à plus de prévention et
d'inspection dans les entreprises mais
aussi à des sanctions judiciaires plus
lourde il alerte également sur la
progression des maladies
professionnelles quelques cent mille
travailleurs meurent chaque année de
cancer liés à l'exposition à des
substances dangereuses sur leur lieu de
travail dénonce la crs au delà de
l'europe 3 millions de personnes
décèdent chaque année dans le monde
d'accident ou de maladie professionnelle
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé